men getting pregnant I had a first
school okay so I I'm gonna give you my
opinion and I you can comment on it I
think it's 99.999 the woman's fault if
she gets pregnant why do you think that
because we are in control of sex
we one there's a million forms of birth
control
two
you can you can
you get to pick who you sleep with yep
and three
there's condoms and four you can even
get an abortion
so I think if you get pregnant it's your
own fault so you said it's 99.9 women's
I think that men out here just shooting
up in random girls are dumb okay I think
you guys are stupid
so do you think so but but I would say
that the responsibility is mostly on the
woman rather than the guy so I I don't
disagree that culturally so
there is more power in the woman in
regards to getting pregnant
but to say that men are only responsible
for one percent of that I disagree I
would say because it does take two to
tango because here's the thing right it
is true that most men would have sex
with anything yeah
but they're the small percentage of men
who maybe have a lot of options wouldn't
they exercise
discipline especially if their time is
money right but even even if let's say
they were a condom right what happened
to Drake
laughs
that doesn't count it does count that
happens to really successful men all the
time no no what I mean is like that's
not that's completely unheard that's not
even one person but that's what I'm
saying like even if a guy wears a condom
a girl can take it
that's not his fault but I would I would
say if she got pregnant from that that's
that's not 99 her that's 100 her yeah
that's none of him yeah I'm saying if it
was if you're gonna oh yeah
um [ __ ] You Drake
No but if um if a guy if a guy has
because if she chooses to have
unprotected sex with him yeah she's
making that text but he's making it okay
but let's say she does who is the who is
the choice to take the Plan B pill
it is her yeah it's true does the man
have any say in that I agree so that's
why I say it's it's her own fault you
could you could okay let's say let's say
one you can track your cycle there's
only like five days yeah in a month or
whatever that you're really likely to
get pregnant I know it can happen
outside of that yeah okay but you can
track your cycle that doesn't work what
can you do a condom okay if that doesn't
work you can get a Plan B pill if that
doesn't work next time around getting
IUD so if that doesn't work no no I'm
not done okay that doesn't work and you
get pregnant you can go get an abortion
the men have no say in this none I know
so so like that's why I said culturally
so I don't understand how these girls
are saying oh it just happened what do
you mean it just happened that I agree
that City like any girls just like oh my
gosh it just happened she got pregnant
like you you played that part yeah
here's my question to you right so
there's like over 40 forms of birth
control for women yeah if it were
reversed there was over 40 forms of
birth control for men yeah but it was
still obviously women who choose who
have sex with so I'm saying the
intersexual Dynamics yes yeah yeah
but in terms of culturally it is men who
has the birth control Power not women
would that then change your position
who's responsible and who's responsible
no because at the end of the day women
men have no say in abortion if you get a
girl pregnant and you're crying to her
and saying I don't want you to get that
abortion there ain't [ __ ] there ain't
[ __ ] you can do you can't save that kid
and so at the end of the day A woman
can't have a child that they don't want
to have
so I fully agree with that I feel like
I'm fully like that's my personal like
if I ever got pregnant so I am sexually
active I'm not on contraception but I
tell men straight away I'm like come in
me don't come on me and I'm like but I
know if that if that happens I'm like
well it's my responsibility to be like
girl you're what what are you doing in
these
[Music]
you clearly did it
would have been that response I was 18
it was the second guy I ever slept with
in my life we were friends we were XYZ
and then I get that text being like hey
and I was like hey he's like oh so um I
uh do you wear a condom uh no okay but
that but that is what I learned people
don't know he didn't he didn't come
inside me either okay but that doesn't
mean you were being response no a lot of
people if you don't know chlamydia is
passed just through contact they don't
need to come inside you so even if
they've got come in here on their hands
what would reduce your odds I mean at
that point I was at that point I was a
very different human being but I'm like
oh I had to come here but you're not
because you're doing the same thing now
well no no because I mentioned everyone
I make sure that everyone also do you
make them get tested and make them yeah
really we don't say clean either so I
was an ex sexual health professional we
don't say clean we say SCD free because
obviously the officer clean is dirty and
we don't we don't perpetuate that like
stigma so I'll say like I I literally
say people and be like hey I'll tell
them I'm like I'm not on contraception
but I I get tested very regularly wait
wait you're not wait you're not on birth
control no no and that is because
I can't and that is because it [ __ ] it
it [ __ ] up my hair I [ __ ] up my body
it [ __ ] up everything you know what
that [ __ ] up your body a baby
but I'm responsible for that I'm
responsible for that what income no no
but what I'm saying is abortion but what
I'm saying is you know what else [ __ ]
up your body
is that I'm like if that happened so I
tell men and they're like oh pull up
method or I'm like okay like if you do
you want to use a condom like cool like
I'm like yeah I'd rather they did but if
I ever got pregnant I wouldn't be like
well it's your fault I'd be like no this
is okay but this is like a point in case
where women are using abortion as a form
of birth control instead of something
that should be used in an emergency oh
no no so like fortunately that's it I'm
27 I've like had a lot of I've had a lot
of casual sex yeah um but that's it I'm
like yeah we will either I'll tell men
and so a lot of men a lot of men that I
sleep with actually to prefer most of
them are like well I'm either not going
to come on you or I'm gonna wear a
condom or I'm like you're just not gonna
finish like okay okay we'll finish in a
another way
um and if a guy is like I'm still gonna
try and finish decide you I'm like no
you're not because like I'll call you
Daddy but I don't want to make you a
daddy like that's literally like
I was saying that's a man all the time I
just want to clarify some understanding
see right now you're in the streets
right yeah yeah yeah your street you're
streeting you know street but even that
is a judgment on women to be like hey
casual sex is not okay for women I
didn't say if it was okay for me what
I'm what I'm what I'm judging you for
I'm gonna be honest yeah yeah it's just
it's just like this is so irresponsible
because if I'm understanding it right
okay so so you're sleeping with these
guys you don't you don't know
okay you date them you date them and
you're not on birth control you have
them finishing you no they don't finish
me no no you're not come on no no no the
opposite the opposite oh okay oh it
doesn't oh no no [ __ ] that's like oh my
God I was gonna correct her but I wanted
to see how far this is
oh my God no okay no no that's my bad oh
no that's not here's the love here's the
honor if you can't come in here come on
her I tell him straight away straight
away I'm like do not finish inside me
and that's why I say I'm like I will
call you Daddy do you want to be a daddy
they all go no no
you're only you don't have them wear
condoms though your only form of is pull
out oh no no like they can wear a condom
but then then it's on the guy that
they're like well I don't want to do you
get to pick so like like do you do you
make them wear a condo I don't make them
if they don't want to okay but then I I
have the conversation with them I'm like
look you've got choices either you don't
finish you wear a condom or you pull out
but I'm well aware that if they don't if
they don't pull out in time I'm like I'm
just trying to be recycled too yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um I get tested very regularly that's it
X sexual health professional sexual
health is the one part of our health
that we are fully responsible for we are
fully responsible for getting tested we
are fully responsible
I do think as an individual as a woman
if if I was to get pregnant from my
Reckless Behavior I'd be like it's not
on you as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible